Hi, I’m Adriene Hill, and Welcome back to
Crash Course Statistics. Sometimes random
variation can make it tricky to tell when
there are true differences or if it’s just random.
Like whether a sample difference of $20 a
month represents a real difference between
the average rates of two car insurance companies.
Or whether a 1 point increase in your AP Stats grade for every hour you study represents
a real relationship between the two.
These situations seem pretty different, but
when we get down to it, they share a similar
pattern. There’s actually one idea, which--with a few tweaks--can help us answer ALL of our
“is it random...or is it real” questions.
That’s what test statistics do. Test statistics allow us to quantify how close things are
to our expectations or theories. Something
that’s not always easy for us to do based
on our gut feelings. And test statistics allow us to add a little more mathematical rigor
to the process, so that we can make decisions about these questions.
INTRO
In previous episodes, z-scores helped us understand the idea that differences are relative.
A difference of 1 second is meaningful
when you are looking at the differences in
the average time it takes two groups of elite Olympic athletes to complete a 100 meter freestyle swim.
It’s less meaningful when you’re
looking at the differences in the average
time it takes two groups of recreational swimmers.
The amount of variance in a group is really
important in judging a difference. Elite Olympic
athletes vary only a little. Their 100 meter
times are relatively close together, and a
10th of a second can mean the difference between a gold and a bronze medal. Whereas non professionals
have more variation; the fastest swimmers
could finish a whole minute before the slower
swimmers.
A difference of 1 second isn't a big deal
between two groups of recreational swimmers
because the difference is small compared to the natural variation we’d expect to see.
Two groups of casual swimmers may differ by 10 or more seconds, even if their true underlying
times were the same, just because of random variation.
That’s why test statistics look at the difference between data and what we’d expect to see
if the null hypothesis is true. But they also
include some very important context: a measure
of “average” variation we’d expect to
see, like how much novice or pro swimmers
differ. Test statistics help us quantify whether data fits our null hypothesis well.
A z-score is a test statistic. Let’s look
at a simple example. Say your IQ is 130. You’re
so smart. And the population mean is 100.
On average we expect someone to be about 15 points from the mean. So the difference we
observed, 30, is twice the amount that we’d
expect to see on average. Your z score would be 2.
And you can z-score any normal distribution--like a population distribution. But also a sampling
distribution which is the distribution of
all possible group means for a certain sample size.
You might remember we first learned
about sampling distribution in episode 19.
We often have questions about groups of people. Finding out that you’re two standard deviations
above the mean for IQ is pretty ego boosting, but it won’t really help further science.
We could look at whether children with more than 100 books in their home have a higher
than average IQs. Let’s say we take a random sample of 25 children with over 100 books.
Then we measure their IQs. The average IQ
is 110.
We can calculate a z-score for our particular group mean. The steps are exactly the same,
we’re just now looking at the sampling distribution of sample means rather than the population distribution.
Instead of taking an individual score and
subtracting the population mean, we take a
group mean and subtract the mean of our sampling distribution under the null hypothesis. Then
we divide by the standard error, which is
the standard deviation of the sampling distribution.
So, the z-score--also called the z-statistic--tells us how many standard errors away from the
sampling distribution mean our group mean is.
Z-statistics around 1 or -1 tell us that the
sample mean is the typical distance we’d
expect a typical sample mean to be from the mean of the null hypothesis.
Z-statistics that are a lot bigger in magnitude than 1 or -1 mean that this sample mean is
more extreme.
Which matches the general form of a test statistic:
The p-value will tell us how rare or extreme
our data is so that we can figure out whether
we think there’s an effect. Like whether
children with more than 100 books in their
home have a higher than average IQ. Historically we’ve done this with tables, but most statistical
programs, even Excel, can calculate this.
We can use z-tests to do hypothesis tests
about means, differences between means, proportions,
or even differences between proportions.
A researcher may want to know whether people in a certain region who got this year’s
flu vaccine were less likely to get the flu.
They randomly sample 1000 people and found
that 600 people got the flu vaccine, and 400 didn’t.
Out of the 600 people who got the vaccine,
20% still got the flu. Out of the 400 people
who did not get the vaccine, 26% got the flu.
It seems like you’re more likely to get
the flu if you didn’t get a flu shot, but
we’re not sure if this difference is pretty
small compared to random variation, or pretty large.
To calculate our z-statistic for this question,
we first have to remember our general form:
There’s a 6% difference between the proportion of the vaccinated and unvaccinated groups,
and we want to know how “different” 6%
is from 0%.
A difference of 0% would mean there’s no
difference between flu rates between the two groups.
So our observed difference is 6 minus 0 percent, or 6%.
For this question, the “average variation”
of what percent of people get the flu is the
standard error from our sampling distribution. We calculate it using the average proportion
of people who got the flu, and didn’t get
the flu:
If our observed difference of 6% is large
compared to the standard error--which is the
amount of variation we expect by chance--we consider the difference to be “statistically
significant”. We’ve found evidence suggesting the null might not be accurate.
There’s two main ways of telling whether
this z-statistic, which is about 2.2295 in
our case, represents a statistically significant result.
The first way is to calculate a “critical”
value. A critical value is a value of our
test statistic that marks the limits of our
“extreme” values. A test statistic that
is more extreme than these critical values
(that is it’s towards the tails) causes
us to reject the null .
We calculate our critical value by finding
out which test-statistic value corresponds
to the top 0.5, 1, or 5% most extreme values. For a z-test with alpha = 0.05, the critical
values are 1.96 and -1.96.
If your z-statistic is more extreme than the
critical value, you call it “statistically
significant”. So, we found evidence...in
this case...that the flu shot is working.
But sometimes, a z-test won’t apply. And
when that happens, we can use the t-distribution
and corresponding t-statistic to conduct a
hypothesis test.
The t-test is just like our z-test. It uses
the same general formula for its t-statistic.
But we use a t-test if we don't know the true population standard deviation.
As you can see, it looks like our z-statistic,
except that we’re using our sample standard
deviation instead of the population standard deviation in the denominator.
The t-distribution looks like the z-distribution, but with thicker tails. The tails are thicker
because we're estimating the true population standard deviation.
Estimation adds a little more uncertainty
...which means thicker tails, since extreme
values are a little more common.
But as we get more and more data, the t-distribution
converges to the z-distribution, so with really large samples, the z and t-tests should give
us similar p-values.
If we’re ever in a situation where we had
the population standard deviation, a z-test
is the way to go. But a t-test is useful when
we don’t have that information.
For example, we can use a t-test to ask whether the average wait time at a car repair shop
across the street is different from the time
you’ll wait at a larger shop 10 minutes away.
We collect data from 50 customers who need to take their cars in for major repairs. 25
are randomly assigned to go to the smaller
repair shop, and the other 25 are sent to
the larger shop.
After measuring the amount of time it took
for repairs to be completed, we find that
people who went to the smaller shop had an average wait time of 14 days. People who went
to the larger shop had an average wait time
of 13.25 days, which means there was a difference
of 0.75 days in wait time.
But we don’t know whether it’s likely
that this 0.75 day difference is just due
to random variation between customers....at least not until we conduct a t-test on the
difference between the means of the two groups.
Before we do our test, we need to decide on an alpha level. We set our alpha at 0.01,
because we want to be a bit more cautious
about rejecting the null hypothesis than we
would be if we used the standard of 0.05.
Now we can calculate the t-statistic for our
two-sample t-test. If the null hypothesis
was true, then there would be no real difference between the mean wait times of the two groups.
And the alternative hypothesis is that the
two means are not equal.
The two sample t-statistic again follows the general form:
We observed a 0.75 day difference in wait
times between groups. We’d expect to see
a difference of 0 if the null were true. Our
measure of average variation is the standard error.
The standard error is the typical distance
that a sample mean will be from the population mean.
This time, we’re looking at the sampling
distribution of differences between means--all
the possible differences between two groups-- which is why the standard error formula may
look a little different.
Putting it all together we get a t-statistic
of about 2.65.
If we plug that into our computer, we can
see that this test statistic has a p-value
of about .0108. Since we set our alpha at
0.01, a p-value needs to be smaller than 0.01
to reject the null hypothesis. Ours isn’t.
Barely, but it isn’t.
So it might have seemed like the larger repair shop was definitely going to be faster but
it’s actually not so clear. And this doesn’t
mean that there isn’t a difference, we just
couldn’t find any evidence that there was
one.
So if you’re trying to decide which shop
to take you car to, maybe consider something
other than speed. And we could do similar
test experiments for cost or reliability or friendliness.
You might notice that throughout the examples in this episode, we used two methods of deciding
whether something was significant: critical
values and p-values.
These two methods are equivalent. Large test statistics and small p-values both refer to
samples that are extreme.
A test statistic that’s bigger than our
critical value would allow us to reject the
null hypothesis. And any test-statistic that’s
larger than the critical value will have a
p-value less than 0.05. So, the two methods
will lead us to the same conclusion.
If you have trouble remembering it, this rhyme may help: “Reject H-Oh if the p is too low”
These two methods are equivalent. But we often use p-values instead of critical values. This
is because each test-statistic, like the z
or t statistics, have different critical values,
but a p-value of less than 0.05 means that
your sample is in the top 5% of extreme samples
no matter if you use a z or t test-statistic
- or some of the other test-statistic we haven’t
discussed like F or chi-square.
Test statistics form the basis of how we can test if things are actually different or what
we seeing is just normal variation. They help us know how likely it is that our results
are normal, or if something interesting is
going on.
Like whether drinking that water upside down is actually stopping your hiccups faster
than doing nothing. Then you can test drinking pickle juice to stop hiccups. Or really slowly
eating a spoonful of creamy peanut butter.
Let the testing commence! Thanks for watching.
I’ll see  you next time.